今日は僕のオススメするアニメの話です皆さんアニメ見ますか
僕はあまり見たい人なんですよ1番は30分ぐらいじゃん
それが大体のアニメって24あるから
全部見たらメッツ時間とられると思ってビデオ借りたり須山で見ないんですよ
ずっと捨てられない
であんまり見ないんですけどそんな動きが訪れメッセルアニメが
この
clannad っていうアニメですそれはなかったです
で画像がこんな感じですこういう
女の子をたくさんすべくアニメなんですか
ねぇ持った奴あー萌えアニメをのように見えて
違うんですよ
このアニメは某サイトでの未来と前世その数アニメランキング大事なんですよ
あまり具体的にはここぞ離さないんですけど
どんな人に見てほしいか
なんかねえ
ぜいぜいがつまんないとか
なんか今の自分がん
いやとか
あすべてに対して不満を持っている人とかっ
てほしいです
ん
すごいんですよ何て言えばいいんだろクラウドっていうアニメなんですけどこれが24
あってその後のアフターストーリーという話があるんですよ僕はそっちの方が見て
ほしい
アフターストーリーのねーもう最後のほうは本当に
やばい
もう今から見てもなければてだけに今から見るから多分あの心揺さぶられて一瞬で
終わっ
10くらいに投げるんですけど本当に何か
2ちゃんねるで clannad は人生って言う
言葉自体もあるぐらいなぁ
すごいアニメなんで見たらきっと
変わると思います本当に前世が見たことある人は彼氏そこの
clannad の素晴らしさ
始めようとは君ん何さ
なんで僕が見ないんですけどこれは本当にヤバイって思った
キーワードとしては何ですかね家族と
恋人と
松とかあと
やっぱおやおやとか具体的にはないんですけど僕はこのはじめ見て
やっぱ親の
親のすごさですね色んな親がいると思うんですやっぱり家庭の事情が
変な家族もあるだろうしていない人も
いると思いますそういう中でそれ中でも頑張っている家族とか
またやっぱ人と人とのつながりとか
思い出すだけれども
グって来ませ本当に本当に頭がぁな人
clannad をしっかり見て
次に clannad after story を
本当に
時間取れば見てほしいですかねいきなり出玉にね最終回とかメール人いるけどねほんと
にやめたほうがいいよ
ちょっと積み重ねてみたら
その第2期のクラナドアフターストーリーの最後でもう
すっごい
感じることがあると思うんで全然楽しくないと思ってる人見たよまじでぜひ
みてください
じゃなんとっ